so what I'm going to talk about today
I'm going to talk about Wikipedia I'm
going to talk about wikia which is my
new project and I'm going to talk about
the future of free culture generally and
some of the things that I see coming
down the road on the internet and so
forth but to kick things off and then
were gonna have questions and answers at
the end so and that's not actually
usually my favorite part because I enjoy
getting questions so in 1962 Charles Van
Doren who was later a senior editor at
botanica said the ideal encyclopedia
should be radical it should stop being
safe but if you know anything about the
history of Britannica since nineteen
sixty-two it's been anything but radical
it's still a very safe very
old-fashioned and very high-quality
encyclopedia project wikipedia on the
other hand began with a very radical
idea and that's for all of us to imagine
a world in which every single person on
the planet is given free access to the
sum of all human knowledge so that's
what we're doing so this vision
statement has several different parts to
it that are very important when we talk
about every single person on the planet
what this means is that wikipedias
mission goes far beyond just English it
goes really all around the world and in
fact if you think about the number of
people who are on the internet versus
the number of people aren't on the
internet there's some interesting
questions about how do we reach all the
people who aren't on the internet how
soon will be on the internet what are
the some of the mechanisms given free
access to the sum of all human knowledge
so free access is important in a very
special way we we mean free in a very
particular sense not in the sense of it
was old saying in the free software
movement we mean free is in speech not
free as in beer so free beers great
somebody gives you free beer you drink
it that's very important that line
always does well on college campuses
but we're talking about something more
fundamental and I'll talk a little bit
more about that in a minute and the sum
of all human knowledge and the word some
there is very important Wikipedia is a
particular kind of reference work so
what is Wikipedia so well first of all I
I always love to ask the question how
many people here have used wikipedia
just sort of okay pretty good but that's
actually just a joke question how many
people here have actually edited
Wikipedia that's actually that's that's
pretty good too and so a lot of people
who simply used wikipedia they may not
really have the full idea of what we're
all about and and some of the philosophy
and some of the ideas behind Wikipedia
so the fundamental definition of
Wikipedia is that it is a freely
licensed encyclopedia written by
thousands of volunteers in many
languages so when I talk about freely
licensed and I talk about free access
what am I talking about well I mean free
in the sense of ganoub reading the sense
of free software or most people know it
as open source software so this is the
some of the ideas outlined by richard
stallman many years ago and the idea is
that there are four freedoms that we
want people to have for all of our work
so you have the freedom to copy it the
freedom to modify it the freedom to
redistribute it and the freedom to
redistribute modified versions and you
can do all of these things commercially
or non-commercially so when people are
contributing to Wikipedia they aren't
just contributing to this particular
humanitarian project they're
contributing to a central storehouse of
knowledge that people can repurpose and
reuse for any purpose they want for all
kinds of different things and that has a
lot of interesting implications
particularly when you reflect on
thinking about how do we reach people in
the developing world who don't have
access to the internet a lot of
interesting things are starting to
happen around that in terms of people
going on and distributing wikipedia on
cd-rom or USB sticks to get it to people
who don't have reliable access to the
internet so free access to knowledge is
really important and if you go back to
written by thousands of volunteers in
many languages this raises the question
of how global is Wikipedia so of course
the english wikipedia is the largest
version of wikipedia with now just over
three million articles
german wikipedia is getting very very
close to 1 million they're going to
class 1 million in the next few weeks
then we have French polish Japanese
Italian Dutch Spanish and Portuguese
with over 500,000 entries each Russian
Swedish and Chinese have over a quarter
million it's interesting though when you
look at this list of languages what you
see here is mostly European languages
the the two exceptions with three
exceptions of Russian but that's you
know Japanese and Chinese but what we
don't see in the top languages are a lot
of the languages of developing world for
all of the sort of normal reasons that
you would expect so when we look at
norwegian as an example I chose
Norwegian because I'm on my way to
Norway and I didn't have to make the
slide twice but it's actually the next
it will pass 250,000 next so in bokmål
which is one of the languages of Norway
they have two hundred and thirty
thousand articles despite the fact that
there are only four point eight million
native speakers of this language so we
can compare that to hindi Hindi has just
over 50,000 articles even though there
are two hundred and eighty million
speakers of Hindi so obviously there's a
big disparity there so what are some of
the reasons for that disparity some of
them are fairly obvious one of them is
access to the internet access to
broadband internet another one is
literacy a lot of the people who are
speaking Hindi aren't necessarily
literate or educated they aren't on the
internet there are some others then the
percentage of people who speak english
is actually a positive for the size of a
local language wikipedia which is sort
of interesting i remember in the early
days of wikipedia is somebody
hypothesized that for example the dutch
wikipedia might not ever do very well
because so many Dutch people speak
perfectly good English but in fact the
opposite has proven true places where
English is very high came to Wikipedia
earlier probably they learned of it
earlier and they've been very very
successful of course we can't omit
mention of the weather because in Norway
it's very very cold there's nothing else
to do in the winter except edit
Wikipedia
you know in India there's lots of things
you can do in the evening so I'm just
joking but there does seem to be the
Northern European countries are very
very strong in Wikipedia so that's kind
of interesting the the Spaniards are as
you can see gaining on the Dutch after
all this time so that's sort of
interesting so so it's a very very
global project although we still are
very interested in it very concerned
about how do we promote Wikipedia how do
we get growth in all the languages
developing world they're only three
languages in Africa that have at least
1000 entries which is very very small
and it's for all of these sort of
obvious reasons we're starting to get
some traction there but there's just a
long way to go so how popular is
Wikipedia we've seen in this room it's
quite popular but looking around the
world Wikipedia is the fifth most
popular website in Germany six most
popular in the u.s. ninth most popular
in India ninth most popular in Japan and
this last one is interesting the 14th
most popular website in Iran one of the
things when we think about Iran a lot of
people don't think of it as the kind of
place that would embrace the kind of
enlightenment values that Wikipedia
represents but it's actually not true
ordinary people everywhere love
Wikipedia they really like the idea of
neutral source of high quality
information recently when the you know
surrounding the Iranian elections there
was a lot of controversy and a lot of
unrest there regarding that and I was
very curious to know what was going on
in the Farsi wikipedia was it going to
be neutral was it going to be really
biased in one direction or the other and
so I asked someone who's a fluent native
speaker of parsi and also a fluent
native speaker of English to translate
the article for me now translating is
always kind of tricky but she told me
that she was really trying to translate
in a very matter-of-fact and just sort
of very plain kind of way without
embellishment and it turned out that the
the the Farsi Wikipedia entry about the
election was very very neutral very
bland just simply stated the basic facts
is exactly what we would hope that
Wikipedia could contribute and this is
one of the reasons that's really popular
they're so very pleased about that now
these popularity numbers are from Alexa
which is maybe sometimes not such a
great source so I won't really a hundred
percent vouch for these but I think in
there in the ballpark so in different
countries and different cultures around
the world Wikipedia is very very similar
but there are some very interesting
differences in different places and I
know this is a little small to read but
I'm going to try to explain to you this
is English Chinese Japanese French
German Russian in Spanish and it's a
look at the most popular entries in
Wikipedia and what subjects are
interesting so as you can see the
Japanese have almost no other interests
than pop culture which is sort of
interesting the the you know geography
is a little bit smaller in english and
then french and german and so on as you
can see in most places around the world
sex is a very popular except for in
france and spain somebody said to me
that's probably because they're actually
having sex
and we're all just reading about it but
this is sort of interesting that there
that there is this difference across
cultures and what's popular in Wikipedia
and this despite the fact that the
Wikipedia communities tend to be very
similar around the world and the
neutrality seems to be very similar
around the world but i just found this
to be quite an interesting observation
so here's another way of looking at the
popularity of Wikipedia this is actually
this charts a little bit old now these
numbers are from comscore so this is
looking at unique visitors and this is a
few months old so at this time we were
the fourth most popular website Google
Microsoft Yahoo the wikimedia foundation
site so that's we keep ed and some of
our other properties and then AOL and
what I actually went back and forth with
AOL for a few months for who was in
fourth place and always said that I'm
sure AOL would pass us permanently soon
because they're so innovative but in
fact the latest numbers have come out
and face book has been roaring ahead and
Facebook just passed us in terms of
unique visitors right now the last
numbers I saw we were at about 330
million unique visitors a month and
facebook is now I think 350 or three 760
million so that's kind of interesting
but our position is secure and we're
continuing to grow but I think this is a
really sort of an amazing thing to think
about so we have this enormous global
impact we're reaching hundreds of
millions of people every month we're in
all of these different languages around
the world and yet the organization
behind Wikipedia is quite unique I mean
when you think about these things often
when I'm talking about Wikipedia people
come up in that they start asking me
questions about the organization and I
don't understand their question at first
until I realize they're trying to figure
out where the campus is the big building
with 3,000 employees something like what
Google or Yahoo would have but in fact
the wikimedia foundation which is the
charity that i found it which runs
wikipedia has a staff of well this
number is out of date now we have a
staff of about 25 people worldwide yeah
three more people I'm afraid we're
getting a little bloated but I think
it's ok so when we think about Wikipedia
the way to think about Wikipedia and
who's creating Wikipedia is that there
is a huge global volunteer community
how many people are in the community
versus not in the community of course
that's very difficult to answer but you
can imagine you know a hundred thousand
active people all around the world who
are in some way committed to and
contributing to Wikipedia and this staff
their job is to support all of those
people so we're a very very tiny
organization last year our budget was
around seven million dollars and for the
coming year our budget's around 10
million dollars so in the grand scheme
of things compared to the you know
multi-billion dollar corporations that
we are ranked with in terms of
popularity we're a very very different
animal I have a short video here which
shows the office and I think the sound
is working so here we go we're going to
see what happens
the wikimedia foundation is the
organization behind wikipedia and age
sister free information projects we're a
huge really popular website were the
number for website in the world 250
million people using it every month and
we're a non-profit an amazingly vibrant
atmosphere and I guess the first thing
that amazed me when I showed up with
just how small the operation is most
people think that it's a fairly large
set of all sorts of editors crazy
mounted developers and manipulators and
really it's not when I first got hired I
thought I'd be walking into a very large
scale company and I walked in and at
that time it was like five people
so the bulk of what we do and the bulk
of the value that's created for the
organization for the projects is done by
volunteers all around the world here in
the office there's a staff of twenty
three people in what we do is facilitate
and support those volunteers in the work
that they're trying to get done there's
a volunteer community who are very much
a part of the organization we are the
smallest part here in San Francisco it's
it's much bigger acknowledges is is
freely available for a much broader
population than it has been in advance
Wikipedia is available in two hundred
sixty four languages the biggest part of
of my work is to broaden the
participation of the Wikipedia language
versions we want to broaden
participation we want to target
particular groups and encourage readers
in those groups to actually become
editors we work with thousands and
thousands of volunteers people who are
not paid at it Wikipedia who do it for
the love of the project we don't pay
people to do that they're not all in one
place it's volunteer it's decentralized
all over the world one thing that a lot
of people don't understand is they can
edit you know they can go in and change
things we want to continually work to
increase the quality of information in
the encyclopedia the natural reflex now
is for people to look stuff up my first
encounter with Wikipedia was obviously
doing research it is the standard bearer
for free knowledge no advertising I say
a common good in the work that I do we
actually see the benefits it's a global
movement and it's free we're trying to
get free information to people
everywhere in the world ok good so so
this is a pretty remarkable project and
it's obviously doing very very well and
but my my vision for the internet and my
vision for free culture is
really much broader than this so the
encyclopedia was the start and if you
think about a traditional encyclopedia
and its role in culture and what a
traditional encyclopedia is a
traditional encyclopedia is so walk into
a library and look for the encyclopedia
it's a set of books about this big you
know it's normally twenty-five to thirty
volumes you know a through z and it has
a certain amount of information but the
library is actually much much bigger
there's a much broader view of the kinds
of things that people can come together
to collaborate on and build so my new
organization is Kia and the relationship
to Wikipedia is that there are
completely separate organizations
wikipedias from 2001 wicke has started
in 2004 Wikipedia is the encyclopedia
and wiki is the rest of the library and
a wikia we have instead of a single
gigantic English website we have some
35,000 different wiki communities who
are building things very specialized
things and I'll give you some of the
examples of those in a moment Wikipedia
is a non-profit and he is a for-profit
company these are advertising supported
wiki's which enables us want to have the
money to actually improve the software
much faster but to it enables us to
support a lot of different kinds of
communities that don't really fit into
the educational and nonprofit kind of
framework so if we look at the
comparative grove of wikia and wikipedia
it's very interesting to see that it's a
very similar kind of pattern I think
that this pattern emerges naturally
because this is about people forming
communities one of the things that that
you have to realize about the way a wiki
community works is that it is a genuine
community people come into a community
they meet other people they make friends
sometimes they make enemies which is
sometimes as much fun as making a friend
and those kinds of things take time
Ginuwine communities take time to come
together figure out what it is they want
to accomplish and so that sort of grossa
comes out in this natural sort of growth
rate so the idea of wikia is the rest of
the library so we have 35 thousand
different wikis we're in 168 different
languages now I would say a hundred and
sick
benign but I don't count Klingon as a
real language we do have a couple of
lengths sites written and Klingon which
I understand doesn't have a past tense
which makes it a little hard to write in
Klingon but they're plugging away and so
but all of these communities are related
by the fact that they're creating
information with enduring value it may
not be encyclopedia content but it's
other kinds of things so wikia our
traffic has been growing a lot even
though probably most people have not
heard of wikia our traffic is now we've
just well we're not connect with the new
york times i just i we they've actually
had a little spike up so today i don't
think we're ahead of the new york times
but we're in the ballpark of the traffic
of the new york times in terms of daily
pageviews which is pretty amazing so
it's interesting to think about what is
going on in the internet what is
happening with free culture what is
happening with consumer-generated media
and what's happening is that consumer
generated media is becoming dominant so
here is I did a search at google for the
keyword muppet to try to see what is
being produced on the internet and
what's interesting here is that in this
on this particular day when I searched
in the top list of links there is
absolutely nothing official there is no
top down media of any kind the official
website you can barely even find it the
number one link as Wikipedia of course
the second link is the muppet central
fansite this is a message board where
people are posting thousands and
thousands of messages about the Muppets
24 hours a day we have not one but two
links to the muppet wiki which is a
wikia site and i'll show you a little
bit more about that later we have the
video results and the video results are
sometimes you know they're from YouTube
and and they are not necessarily
sometimes they're official sometimes
they're parodies it varies what with
google links to but they're all being
drawn from blogs and fan sites for the
most part where people are discussing
the Muppets or there's a conversation
about the Muppets we have the muppet
newsflash which is a blog about the
Muppets
so in this whole top group of sites
they're all they're all communities
they're all consumer-generated the
muppet wiki here is a really great wiki
and they have written eighteen thousand
nine hundred and thirty five articles
about the Muppets you know what are they
doing do they have jobs well it turns
out a lot of them do have jobs they just
also have this passion for the Muppets
and keep in mind this is not 18,000
message board posts this is eighteen
thousand entries some long some short
most edited by more than one person but
these are very much entries very similar
to what you would find in a Wikipedia
entry so what is different about wikia
versus Wikipedia how is why is this
stuff all not in Wikipedia well if we
look at the entry in wikipedia about the
Ford Motor Company it's very much what
you would expect from Wikipedia it tells
the history of the company it tells
about the current management and sales
pretty much all of the things that you
would expect to find out about the Ford
Motor Company although this entry for
reasons that are maybe mysterious to
some people completely fails to mention
the time when Kermit was on a commercial
but this is the only thing the Muppet
people care about
for them the Ford Motor Company is
pretty much only represented by the fact
that you know you know the famous Kermit
has a song it's not easy being green it
turns out it is easy being green you
just have to buy a Ford hybrid SUV so
who know but what's interesting here is
in this is an in 2006 there was also an
earlier thing if you go further down but
they've really researched this and so
what we're seeing in this particular
wiki is people who are looking at one
very broad pop culture franchise and
they're thinking about how does this
intersect with the rest of the world how
does this intersect with everything in
the world and so they're coming up with
something if you try to put this picture
into the english-language wikipedia I
think you would be blocked in about 15
seconds right because for Wikipedia the
purpose of Wikipedia is to document very
serious information about the Ford Motor
Company it's a very different purpose
than what's going on here now one of the
things that I think is interesting when
we think about free culture when we
think about participatory culture and
the things that are happening here we
often think about the internet really in
terms of how is the new competing with
or replacing the old so we think about
how do political bloggers compete with
the editorial page of the New York Times
we think about how does Wikipedia
compete with prett annika but what we're
seeing here is something entirely new
something very different there has never
before existed I mean if you go to to
Amazon or to Barnes and Noble or any
major bookstore and you look for books
about the Muppets there's a lot of books
about the Muppets some of them officials
some of the munna fishel but there is
never existed and encyclopedia about the
intersection of Muppets with the rest of
the world with 18,000 entries we never
had an economic model that could sustain
the kind of work there was passion for
these kinds of topics but now we have a
tool that's allowing people for the
first time to create new types of
reference works that we never even
imagined could have existed before if
you tried to produce something like this
in a top-down manner trust me you really
couldn't I mean it would it would cost
you a fortune and there'll be no way to
recoup your money but when you have a
community who comes together and says
hey let's create something really
amazing and really cool they can do this
kind of thing so we have all kinds of
things like lostpedia which is about the
TV show Lost fabulous show I actually
had the opportunity to meet JJ Abrams
who's the creator of lost and he's like
oh my god I love lostpedia and at this
time we didn't own it so I was like oh
yeah it's really great i had to go out
and buy it but and but you know and
we've had situations so some of our very
popular sites are about video games
we've had situations where we found out
incidentally that the video game
developers are actually relying on the
community lore and culture from the wiki
to develop the new versions of the game
so there was a case where in one of our
wikis there is a character in the game
that didn't really have a name and so
they just sort of gave him a name so
they could refer to him in the next
version of the game that was his name
and so that's how we sort of knew the
developers were looking at it they're
like the world of warcraft wiki due to
the same buddy here play World of
Warcraft does anybody admit it come on
so Warcraft I mean this is a game with I
think like 11 million players so I think
more than the three people who raised
their hand probably a flight Warcraft in
this room so it's a huge thing and
there's there's the wowwiki and wowwiki
which is all about the world of warcraft
they've written more than 70,000
articles and some of them are just
documenting the game walkthroughs and
things like this but a lot of it is
documenting the culture within the game
documenting different guilds and groups
within the game and so it's really
amazing kinds of things that really we
have no other way of creating so my next
point is one there's a particular term
that people are using for this kind of
thing and I think it's horrible the word
crowdsourcing I think crowdsourcing is a
term that we should vanish because I
think that it it is a misunderstanding
of what's going on and I think that
companies and organizations that think
about what's going on in terms of
crowdsourcing are going to make huge
mistakes and big blunders because they
don't really get what's going on it
isn't crowdsourcing the terminology of
crowdsourcing it's it's a it's a it's a
new term that's coin based on the idea
of outsourcing so the idea of outsourced
is we can't afford to hire expensive
engineers in California so we're going
to hire cheaper ones in India or
somewhere like this we're going to
outsource certain parts of our work to
India it's about finding the cheapest
labor and crowdsourcing yet is that the
crowdsourcing is G we have certain work
we need to have done let's trick the
public into doing it for free somehow
and I think that when people approach it
in this way they're making a huge
mistake and I think it really is an
offensive term for people in the
communities who are doing things so
what's wrong with it so imagine that
you're running a bowling alley I see a
few people have seen the movie imagine
that you're running a bowling alley and
you imagine that what you're doing there
is that you've got a certain amount of
bowling that needs to be accomplished
and you're trying to get people to do
the work of bowling for free so you're
you're deeply confused about what
business you're in you're deeply
confused about what you're doing and
this is where you get a lot of very
strange sort of comments in the press
people say she wanna people work for
free for Wikipedia some people get paid
a lot of money too right so why are
people doing this work for free that's a
lot like asking gee you know I read
about this guy he makes a million
dollars a year as a professional bowler
can you tell me how you get people to do
this work for free that's a stupid thing
to ask obviously right people do bowling
because it's a fun activity and if
you're if you're running a bowling alley
and you think that what you're trying to
do is get people to do work for free
you've totally misunderstood what's
going on instead you should say what I'm
doing is I'm providing a place a clean
well-lighted place where people can come
with their friends we have good beer and
bad hot dogs you can bowl it's a
community a lot of bowling alleys really
are thriving the ones that are thriving
it's kind of getting to be an outdated
sport I guess these days but they're
very community-oriented they run leagues
so that different groups of people can
get together and play and organize
tournaments and things like this they're
very aware that their job is to
facilitate a community who wants to have
some fun and do the things they want to
do so this is my view we're not trying
at Wikipedia or wikia we don't think oh
well there's some work we need doing
let's try and make it so the public will
do it for us instead we say what are the
things that a community could do what
are the
things that people really want to do but
they don't have the tools that they need
to accomplish what they want to
accomplish and I think by approaching it
in that way we're far more successful at
meeting people's actual needs and and
getting things accomplished so finally I
want to close with a little bit of the
philosophy behind wikis and behind
Wikipedia and what I really want to talk
about is this the ideas of openness why
do I believe so much in in this kind of
open model there's all these questions
about trust and vandalism and what do we
think about that so I want you to all to
imagine that you've been assigned the
task of it's a design task and you've
been asked to design a restaurant so
you're going to design a restaurant and
you are thinking about it from scratch
you can you can do anything you want I
want you to you know blank sheet of
paper imagine how to design the
restaurant so you think to yourself okay
well in my restaurant I know we're going
to be serving steak and if we're serving
steak then I know that the customers are
going to need to have access to knives
and if there's anything that we know
about customers with knives is that they
might stab people so therefore we'd
better put everybody in a cage so in my
restaurant I'm going to put a cage
around every table so that everybody's
safe but we all laugh at this right we
know that this kind of thinking makes a
bad society this is not how we think
about restaurant design even though it
actually is true that if you let people
have access to knives it happens very
rarely that people will stab each other
there's a small minority of people who
do something bad but what do we do about
this in in society generally the way we
deal with this is not by thinking in
terms of a gatekeeper model we don't say
well you know before we give you your
knife you're going to have to you know
be in a cage instead we we say we've
evolved customs and institutions to deal
with problems after they arise so what
happens in reality if somebody comes
into a restaurant and have a knife and
they start to stab somebody well we have
certain first of all certain social
norms about what's supposed to happen
one of the things that happens is that
like this guy here he's a big guy in the
front row and he's gonna hopefully jump
up and tackle the person and if he does
we say that's very heroic and we thank
you you're very brave because you're a
big guy you can knock him down somebody
else is calling the police and calling
for an ambulance so we have the
institutions of the police and the jails
in the prison system to deal with the
bad person the ambulance is so that
whatever bad thing has happened we do
our best to try to correct it you know
we're going to say let's so the person
up and you know what sometimes this
doesn't work tragedies do happen and
that's a cost but it's a cost that we
accept we say we would rather live in a
society where people sit next to each
other in a restaurant and generally
trust each other even though
occasionally bad people do bad things
then that's preferable to living in a
society where everything is a priority
has to be checked and nobody has trusted
this is one of the reasons that airports
are so sort of inhuman and unpleasant
because you walk into an airport and
they treat you like you're a criminal
and it generates a very negative feeling
we don't want that in society
unfortunately on the internet when
people think about design of social
spaces it's all too easy to fall into
the trap of thinking GD I'm going to
think first of all of the bad things
people might do and I'm going to design
my system around that I want to make
sure that nothing bad can possibly
happen so I need all these permission
models and controls and who's authorized
to do what but in so doing we eliminate
the possibility for the all kinds of
normal human action all kinds of simple
kindnesses and people helping each other
because it's very difficult to design
systems of security they don't interfere
with systems of kindness so my belief is
when we're thinking about design on the
internet we should think in this open
manner we should think about how do we
design social institutions and norms to
correct and minimize the problems that
are inevitably going to happen and well
fortunately on the internet it's digital
so you can you know if someone it's not
like getting stabbed right you can
always revert back you can always change
things back there are some harms that
can happen on the internet that can't be
easily corrected but that's part of the
price of living in an open society and I
think it's worthwhile so that's the end
of my prepared remarks so thank you very
much
and
now we have plenty of time for open
questions and I can take bad Jim can you
tell me what in the eight years might be
the most surprising criticism you've
received for Wikipedia and what do you
foresee is some of the counter arguments
to some of the critics of open open
media I don't know there's a lot of
criticisms that are surprising in some
fashion I guess one that eternally
surprises me although it shouldn't is
there there is this story arc in the
press that they just simply cannot
resist which is a story that says
headline always says wikipedia imposes
new restrictions and it doesn't matter
what policy changes we make that's the
interpretation so several years ago what
we used to do is we only have one tool
for dealing with a persistent vandalism
or a problem an article which was to
protect it so we would lock the article
and when it's locked no one can edit it
except for the administrators who buy
custom don't edit while it's locked and
so we said but we don't like this that's
really a bit too harsh and too strong in
many cases it would be sufficient if we
could just prevent certain people so we
invented something called semi
protection when an article is semi
protected anonymous IP numbers can't
edit you have to create an account and
you have to have your account for four
days and then you're able to edit it so
this was a step towards saying look we
want to open it up we want to have a lot
more people allowed to edit rather than
having to lock things down like this
well as soon as we introduce my
protection the headline was Wikipedia
introduces new page controls right and
restrictions so now we're moving to a
system of we call it flag protection or
flag revisions where instead of those
early people who are you know new in the
community instead of not being able to
edit at all we're now allowing them to
edit at all to edit the articles but
somebody more experienced in the
community will review the reddits this
has been interpreting the press as
wikipedia you know boards of senior
editors will now review contributions
from newcomers or you only say newcomers
but you know countries so that
bizarre to me right it's like people
can't get their minds around the idea
that quite possibly the openness
actually works and that yes of course
we're always learning and trying to
tweak the model but that the possible
advances and how to manage the community
and how to give the community the tools
to manage themselves aren't always about
introducing gatekeeping so that's kind
of a surprising thing although I should
get used to it eventually how do I
answer some of the different criticisms
I mean it depends i mean sometimes there
are criticisms which are unfair and some
of them are fair so if somebody
vandalizes wikipedia and something you
know some insult is in wikipedia for one
minute and then a reporter happens to
notice it and runs a story about it i
think you know that's a little bit
unfair right it's not it's vandalism
with Wikipedia you get used to it it
sometimes will happen in other times you
know if we have an error that persists
for several months I think that's a
legitimate thing to criticize us for so
I you know and my answer to that is well
we're trying to develop better tools so
give the community the tools they need
to be able to manage things so yeah I
guess that's my answer hi um I was
wondering if you could speak on the
influence of Wikipedia on academic
publishing or the future of academic
publishing in the world of Wikipedia so
i think i think the influence of
wikipedia in the world of academic
publishing is very very small at this
point and probably will remain so I mean
we're an encyclopedia which is a very
very different thing from a
peer-reviewed academic journal and we're
not trying to be a peer-reviewed
academic journal and I think we
shouldn't be at the same time there's a
lot of very interesting stuff going on
in the world of peer-reviewed academic
journals as there is a very broad open
access movement where people are very
interested in saying that the products
of academic research should be freely
and very widely available that's a very
a scholarly idea of what academic
research should be about and it's also
it's an interesting thing that the
business model of traditional academic
journals is you know
the the people who are writing don't get
paid the people who are reviewing don't
get paid and the journals cost a lot of
money that sounds like a vulnerable
business model to me on the other hand i
love this everybody turn around and look
citation needed that's a very good XKCD
come up afterwards and we'll get a
picture with that because i love it so
at the same time the the function that
traditional academic journals play is an
important function and so thinking about
as a lot of academics are thinking about
how do we replace that function how do
we have a system of peer review that
doesn't involve that bottleneck which is
a very expensive bottleneck particularly
for people say in the developing world
who really have a very difficult time
accessing the most recent academic
research because they can't afford the
journals there are some there's some
progress being made in that area one of
the projects that I think is worth
taking a look at is +1 so this is Public
Library of Science and they have a
system plus one which is an online peer
review mechanism that I hear is going
pretty well but they're still exploring
and figuring out how to make it better
so I think that academic research is
changing academic publishing s sa is
changing and it's it's I think that's I
think there's good progress being made
in that area if you're interested in
open access at Yale come talk to me
afterward um let's get one back here hi
i'm very interested in this idea of
openness as a way to affect kind of a
social change and i think that you know
the wikipedia model has revolutionized
the way we distribute knowledge what
other avan are areas of life is do you
see technology and openness affecting
bitter that are outside of the ceramic
knowledge so i guess one of the one of
the areas is open access publishing in
academics which we just discussed
another area with that i think is really
really important is free licensing and
free access to information produced by
the government
and so the US for the most part is one
of the leaders in this because for you
know and under US law anything that's
produced by the US government is
automatically in the public domain which
is a really one of the thing that's not
true in many countries around the world
and I think that's been really important
so any kind of reports produced by the
Department of Agriculture and things
like that it's in the public domain
people can take in and repurpose it and
do different things with it I feel like
that needs to be extended in a lot of
way so one of the things that happens
today is that we see funding for
academic research in the form of a grant
so I'll give you a classic example I
read about it there was a grant for the
production of an encyclopedia of poets
in Virginia right a very narrow subject
and I think it was even sort of in the
1800s right a very narrow three-volume
work and this was supported by a
government grant and the question of
whether the government should be
supporting that sort of thing or not is
an interesting one that I you know not
going to go into but I will say if the
taxpayers paid for it it should be
freely available and what's the terrible
irony is this is that those articles
were written very diligently by very
qualified people the books were sent out
bought by you know I don't know how many
couple hundred academic libraries and
they're sitting on a shelf getting dusty
today and nobody's reading it whereas if
that information had been under a free
license the Wikipedia community could
have made it easily available to the
entire world and if we as taxpayers are
paying for that kind of research
shouldn't we expect that it be
distributed in the most efficient manner
and a free license is the right way to
do that there's a lot of other things
that are interesting going on there are
a lot of really good people now in the
Obama administration who are really
pushing for a lot more sort of open
distribution of just raw data sets and
things like this there's a lot of
information that's locked up in the
government not for any ideological
reason but just because this is a new
way of thinking they think oh we've got
all this raw data but we're going to
somehow process it and make a report and
they don't think of just like yeah put
all your data online and let anybody who
wants to come and download and do it
things with it so I think that's an
important area where we're going to see
a lot of progress because of these ideas
of openness I guess there's a lot of
other areas you know but I don't know
how did you come to like meet your
co-founder for Wikipedia what what did
the you know that relationship bring to
the you know the beginning of the the
organization and where did he go okay so
I I had none Larry from the internet for
some time and when I had the idea to
have a free encyclopedia for everyone i
contacted him and then I hired him to
work for me as the editor-in-chief of
New pedia and that was what we called
the first project Larry and I had a lot
of discussions and debates about you
know how to do things it was very
interesting a sort of exchange and what
we ended up with was that we designed a
very top-down system a very hierarchical
system there was a seventh stage review
process I remember he was having people
facts in their their resume to show that
they were qualified to write an article
well at the time that seemed like the
only reasonable approach i mean we felt
like we wanted our project to be
respectable and we knew that if it was
coming from the crazy internet we needed
to take extra steps to make it
respectable so that seemed reasonable at
the time turns out it was a complete
failure one of the reasons it was a
failure is that for volunteers who want
to contribute it was a very intimidating
system so after spending a lot of money
on this and I was getting very
frustrated cuz we weren't having any
progress I decided to write an article
myself and I had been an academic I was
working on a PhD in finance and I had
published a paper on option pricing
theory very mathematical field and
Robert Merton had recently won the nobel
prize in economics for his work in
option pricing theory and I thought I
can write a five paragraph biography of
this guy right I had been out of
academia for a few years and but I was
you know I
his work and I thought I can do this and
I sat down to write the article and I
was like super intimidated because I
knew that when I submitted my first
draft they were going to take it and
send it out for review not just a two
random finance professor somewhere but
the most prestigious ones they could
find and they were going to give me
comments on the article and I was gonna
have to revise it and it was like you
know it was like grad school all over
again and it wasn't very fun it was very
intimidating and so I had a bit of
writer's block i couldn't do it and that
was when I realized like this really
isn't going to work so then we someone
across the wiki editing concept and the
wiki editing model had been around since
1995 and so I downloaded the wiki
software and installed it and we started
you know we told the new PD a community
hey we've got this new tool come and
take a look at it and we got more work
done in two weeks time than we had done
in almost two years I mean it was really
remarkable that we had this community
people who were very excited about this
idea this vision of a free encyclopedia
but they were very frustrated by the
system so after that you know there was
just a long long process Larry
eventually I won't speak for his reasons
but he became too satisfied with the
project and moved on and started a maybe
you call a competing project called
citizen diem where instead of how is
sort of a more of a hybrid basically
everybody was going to have to have some
kind of credentials and basically use
their real name and be authorized to do
things but it was still going to use the
wiki for the editing process since
vindium has not been particularly
successful though there's a community
they're still working and I know Larry
just announced that he's leaving says
Cindy him so I'm not really sure what
he's doing today I we have time for a
few more questions hey I was wondering
have you ever edited your own Wikipedia
page and alternatively have you ever
been surprised to spine the wikia on
something you were searching for an
answer for surprised to find what like a
wiki on something you were looking for
okay yes so I have edited my Wikipedia
page years ago I edited openly under
name and within the community this was
not considered controversial but the
press noticed it and sort of said Oh big
scandal you know said I was caught
editing my entry I'm like how was that
caught yeah I edited under my own name
but I decided I shouldn't do that
anymore and yeah so in general we
recommend to people today that they not
edit their own entry and also to not
edit anything that you might conceivably
have a conflict of interest about there
are some exceptions that it's not a hard
and fast rule it's more of a guideline
simple exception would be you know if
your date of birth is wrong or you're
and assuming your date of birth is not
controversial there used to be a section
in my entry called a date of birth
controversy because i was born on a
certain day but my birth certificate
says the next day because the doctor
must have been very sleepy and made an
error because i was born very late at
night so legal documents say a different
thing from what my mom tells me i trust
my mom other people say she's not a
reliable source so no but in general you
know things like the address or the
location of a company things like that
of course a company could come in and
edit if it's uncontroversial you know
you know somebody you know the CEO left
and you have a new CEO and it's just an
update but in general we tell people you
know go to the discussion page and post
there and really it's more respectful of
the community to do it that way the
second question have i ever been
surprised that there was a wiki about a
certain topic that i searched for no not
really not anymore especially i mean i
think i'm more surprised if there's not
an entry about something you know
because wikipedia is very very
comprehensive i mean i was surprised i
remember there's some really humorous
entries in wikipedia one of my favorite
ones is called inherently funny words
and the story of this is somebody
created it i believe almost as a joke
right but then people you know it was
almost deleted excuses so but it turns
out that a lot of famous come
medians have talked about this concept
that when you're telling a joke or
you're saying something humorous that
your specific word choices can be very
funny and you there's Jerry Seinfeld's
talk about it woody allen Krusty the
Clown from The Simpsons has talked about
it and so then somebody went through and
the article was just a mess with people
inserting all kinds of random things
that they thought were funny and
somebody said no this could be a good
article but we have to cite our sources
and so somebody went through the article
in very very firmly said no we have to
have a specific source of a well-known
comedian who talked about this concept
and what they had to say about it before
we add this word to the list of
inherently funny words and so it became
a pretty good article after that so you
know so it's things like badger see it's
true it's an inherently funny word okay
so that was sort of surprising I guess
to find that hi so what do you see in a
future dove Wikipedia and we cared and
also in more general terms where you see
in the future would have user-generated
content on the internet where they've
become the main string or even the you
know army only thing that's a prospering
can you elaborate on that so when I
think about the future of Wikipedia in
particular the main thing that I'm
focused on is the growth of Wikipedia in
the developing world so in a lot of the
the languages of India for example we're
experiencing as much as ten percent
monthly growth in the number of entries
right now there's about more than 1
billion people in line but it's like 1.1
billion people online depending on who
says and how you measure it but in the
next five to 10 years we expect to have
the next billion people come online and
they're not going to be coming online
from Europe the US and Japan they're
going to be coming online in China in
India Africa South America and I think
that's going to have a huge cultural
impact as all of those people are coming
on and beginning to interact with the
global community in a new way so I think
of the future of Wikipedia in those
terms broad early are speaking more
broadly
I think that wikia is probably not going
to be as popular as Wikipedia maybe it
will someday but it's going to be a lot
bigger than Wikipedia because instead of
having one entry on the Ford Motor
Company we're going to have hundreds of
entries on the ford motor company as
consider from many different perspective
you know uncyclopedia is a parody of
wikipedia and it's going to have a funny
article about ford the muppet wiki has
an article for you know is it I like all
the other books in the library and then
talking about all user generated content
I think that in terms of participatory
culture which is what I'm more
interested in simply user-generated but
thinking about how communities are
coming together to do things and build
things I'm really interested in what's
going on in video and I think there's
going to be a lot of interesting things
happen there with groups of people
coming together probably not so much in
a broad giant collaboration like
Wikipedia more in small teams like the
way that open source software is done to
create you know new forms of video art
and content but I and I'm thinking
really popular stuff too I'm not just
saying you know smoke over the people
doing sort of quirky art videos is
interesting but what I'm more interested
in is are we going to see a situation in
15 years where there's going to emerge a
certain folk culture so that the at you
know that the harry potter of 2025
instead of being a single author who
wrote this thing that became a large
french I've that instead it emerges in a
collaboration with a lot of people
online I don't know the answer to that
but I'm very interested to see if they
can happen and I've seen some really
interesting and amazing projects already
where people are producing you know film
that's actually very impressive quality
either animation or live film and I
think there's a lot of interesting
things that are going to happen there so
maybe one more question here on the end
of the rope to more so okay sometimes
when I start doing preliminary research
i'll look at the Wikipedia article and
then I'll go to another website and it's
the exact same wording and it's always
unclear which website had that wording
first but I was wondering if you see
this as plagiarism or just
effective use of open source knowledge
so if we copied something directly from
another website I think that's
plagiarism and it's very very very bad
and we found on that very very much one
of the things that we're really is
really important to the Wikipedia
community it's not just policing for
copyright violations but actually it's a
broader ethical point then copyright
which is a specific legal point it's
when people look at wikipedia whatever
criticism people might have of Wikipedia
we can stand up and say with pride we
made it ourselves nobody's ever going to
save Wikipedia yeah it's pretty good
that's just because they ganked
everything out of Britannica right not
true so we don't like to see that if
somebody is taking content from
Wikipedia the main thing that we would
ask is that they respect our license the
Creative Commons license that it's under
which is attribution share-alike so we
would say attribution you need to say
where you got it from you're allowed to
modify it or whatever and you need to
make sure that your version is also
posted under that licence that other
people are allowed to copy it on the
other hand if people just copy it
without attribution and so on it's not
good but we don't get too wound up about
it I mean some people in the community
get very wound up about it but I
personally think you know it's bad but
whatever I got more important things to
do than yell at people for copying
Wikipedia so okay and so now one more
question where's the microphone so in
your speech you talked a lot about the
community I just have a question do you
really think that the aggregate
knowledge from a community is better
than the knowledge produced by a single
expert it also has any event since the
founding of Wikipedia upsetting you
about you know your optimism about the
power of community and how have you
sustained you're facing that so I think
that I think that I have to be very
careful in answering this question
because I think my position is a little
bit nuanced I think that for creating an
encyclopedia article a collaborative
community approach is superior to a
single expert and the reason is an
encyclopedia article should not be
innovative original research that's not
what an encyclopedia article is so if we
imagine for example a that say that the
history of psychology as written by BF
Skinner or Sigmund Freud two very
different Giants in the field with a
very different view of the world in my
opinion it's more likely than not that a
review of psychology written by BF
Skinner is going to be a remarkable
historical document that is very
valuable but is not in fact but I want
from an encyclopedia article what I want
is a neutral presentation where there's
been a lot of give and take and dialogue
about what you go in there by people who
are very thoughtful and knowledgeable
and so in a case like that I would say
yes on the other hand if you're talking
about writing a fabulous novel or a poem
which is an you know another form of
knowledge about the world I don't see
collaboration is necessarily the best
approach if you're talking about an
editorial opinion I really want a strong
individual personal voice their of
someone who will stand behind that
opinion and there's nothing wrong with
that so I think it really depends on the
specific domain and what you're
particularly trying to accomplish has
there any been anything that really sort
of shook my faith in the power of
community i'm going to say basically no
i mean there have been times when I've
been very frustrated by what some
individual [ __ ] is doing but in general
the Wikipedia community has generally
always come to the right conclusions in
my opinion you know certainly I may
disagree about this or that particular
decision that gets made but in general I
would say if you get together a decent
sized group of thoughtful people they
end up making pretty good decisions and
this is one of the things that I think a
lot of people who aren't part of the
Wikipedia world don't really understand
they think of Wikipedia as a complete
anarchy with all kinds of crazy things
going on when in fact it's really it's a
community of people and and you know
when you think about things like let's
say the naming conventions for things I
was for a while i was on a on a mailing
list of news librarians i don't know
I got on it but I was on a mailing list
of news librarians and they were
discussing before the winter olympics i
guess it was in turin or Torino they
were saying what are you what are your
newspapers calling it turin or Torino
because it's kind of changing over time
as to which name to use and I thought
gee I wonder what Wikipedia does and
what I went I went and found the the
entry not in but in the style guidelines
about the question of naming conventions
for cities in different places and I
could just as anybody might quibble with
this at that point but in general I
thought wow I mean I can't believe that
we've got this enormous document with a
very nuanced discussion of win and why
you would name something using the
traditional name as it's known in
English or use a more local name and
it's a really thoughtful discussion
that's very hard to think of this as
like crazy random people doing wrong
things even if you don't agree with the
particular decision so in general I mean
I think that part of things really works
very well so I guess we're out of time
so thank you everyone for coming and I
hope that I hope that you will all
consider the invitation to get involved
with free culture group here at Yale a
lot of these groups are doing a really
interesting things at different
universities and the most important
thing is it's a lot of fun so and I
believe